wo sollen wir nur hin wenn es selbst in
deutschland im sommer unerträglich heiß
wird im süden ist es ja noch heiß am
beispiel in den hier wird die dürre
immer dramatischer die fünf
millionenstadt chennai hat kein wasser
mehr aber noch mehr insgesamt 330
millionen menschen sind dort von der
wasserknappheit betroffen und auch hier
in deutschland droht 120000 menschen in
ostwestfalen schon jetzt der
wassernotstand ist das der anfang vom
ende klicks um 20 in fiction hier gibt
es täglich faszinierendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen es
spricht einiges dafür dass diese
extremwetterereignisse mit dem
klimawandel zusammenhängen das problem
konkrete ereignisse kann man eigentlich
meist nicht mit dem klimawandel
verbinden und ihm zu ordnen allerdings
passieren immer mehr unwetter oder
stürme die zumindest statistisch
inzwischen deutlich wahrscheinlicher
geworden sind und vor allem gehen damit
immer größere mengen wasser auf uns
nieder es ist also nicht nur die
bodenversiegelung die straßen häuser und
gewerbegebiete wie das wasser immer
schlechter abfließen lassen es regnet
oder hagel tatsächlich mehr wasser auf
uns nieder
und dafür gibt es hier in europa einen
ganz einfachen grund die arktis verliert
immer mehr eis vor allem im sommer
und so sind immer größere flächen
eisfrei und damit wird das wasser weil
es deutlich weniger sonnenlicht als eis
reflektiert wärmer und so verdunsten
riesige mengen an wasser die jetzt als
regen oder hagel in bisher fast
unbekannten mengen auf uns
niederprasseln und auch die hitzewelle
dieses jahr wird mit dem klimawandel in
verbindung gebracht nachdem mozilla tief
einer der führenden deutschen
klimaexperten bisher diese zusammenhänge
immer wieder in frage gestellt hat ist
er inzwischen überzeugt dass hier ein
viel deutlicher zusammenhang besteht was
aber auch an den extremereignissen liegt
der professor des helmholtz zentrums für
ozeanforschung hat in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten den trend zur temperaturen
über 30 grad in den sommermonaten
festgestellt im spiegel sagte er dazu
das ist ein deutliches zeichen dass die
menschengemachte erderwärmung das wetter
beeinflusst sprich genau diesen sommer
und die
die hitzewelle kann man nicht
zweifelsfrei dem klimawandel zu
schreiben die häufung allerdings schon
und wie hoch die wahrscheinlichkeit für
dieses wetter ereignisse im zusammenhang
mit dem klimawandel ist auch dafür gibt
es sogar einen eigenen und neuen
wissenschafts begriff die zuordnung
wissenschaft attributen science hierbei
geht es ganz konkret darum
herauszufinden welchen zusammenhang es
zwischen wetter und klima gibt
gearbeitet wird daran am environmental
change institut in oxford hier ist man
in der lage jedem bett ereignis auch den
anteil und die wahrscheinlichkeit des
zusammenhangs mit dem klimawandel
zuzuordnen
für den wahnsinns sommer im letzten jahr
mit einer erstmals seit der wette
erfassung komplette warmen nordhalbkugel
wurde von dem institut eine deutlich
höhere wahrscheinlichkeit im
zusammenhang mit dem klimawandel
errechnet konkret war die
wahrscheinlichkeit für die hohen
temperaturen in kopenhagen im
zusammenhang mit dem klimawandel fünfmal
höher möglich wird das durch den
vergleich der verschiedenen klimamodelle
in einer welt ohne den menschengemachten
klimawandel und mit ihm dabei werden
simulationen gegen das wetterereignis
gestellt das untersucht wird dabei
werden unmengen an daten erfasst und mit
speziellen algorithmen durchgerechnet
die die deutsche leiterin des instituts
die klima wissenschaftlerinnen und
physikerin friederike otto mitentwickelt
hat sie sagt zu dem verfahren zum ersten
mal in der geschichte verfügen wir über
die mittel um belastbare aussagen über
einzelne wetterereignisse zu treffen das
zitat stammt aus ihrem buch wütendes
wetter mit ihrer methode wird so otto
die klimawissenschaft gewissermaßen vom
kopf auf die füße gestellt und es
eröffnen ganz neue rechtliche
perspektiven zum ersten mal kann wetter
kausal mit dem klimawandel in
zusammenhang gebracht werden und da
ziemlich exakt bekannt ist wer wie viel
in welcher weise zum klimawandel
beiträgt können die verantwortlichen die
ölkonzerne regierung stromkonzerne wie
rwe und so weiter und so fort verklagt
werden da ja alle im wissen und
erkenntnis der auswirkungen ihres tuns
handeln dürfte es grobe fahrlässigkeit
sein die hier zum tragen kommt das heißt
angela merkel und die chefs und
chefinnen der konzerne
dürften auch persönlich haften das wird
im wahrsten sinne des wortes ein langer
prozess
aber man kann nur hoffen dass er gerecht
geführt wird laut trainer otto werden
solche klagen bereits mit ihren daten
vorbereitet ja ihr habt euch entschieden
und wollte einen kanal zum thema natur
und umwelt das habt ihr unter dem video
ist der klimawandel noch aufzuhalten
kommentiert und auch unter der infoguard
abgestimmt 60 prozent waren unter der
infoguard dazu und dass es hier mehr
videos dazu gibt wer natürlich machen
und wir werden den kanal machen also wer
wirst mit zu machen schreibt an info at
magix.net wir brauchen moderatoren
moderatorin leute die recherchieren die
schreiben und so weiter und so fort ich
freue mich auf eure rückmeldung und hier
geht es weiter mit
ist der klimawandel noch aufzuhalten
natürlich anklicken anschauen und klicks
und science fiction abonnieren falls das
noch nicht getan haben
bis dann bleibt dran